please don't compare me to this dude at
all are you out of your mind
well no you said yourself you've had
your wild days right nothing like this
he was incredibly candid and honest with
me about what he went through and a lot
of times he would we would talk about
sections in the book and say Not only
was it that bad I was 10 times worse and
I'm going to tell you why I was so
determined to suck every bit of
information from me and any any stuff
that wasn't in the book and sort of you
know what was on my mind this is the
second project in my life that I kind of
stuck with for over six years and have
been obsessed with playing he got to
where he is not just through town but
also through hard work countless hours
you know hundreds of hours he was just
learning everything about my body
language how I speak my language
patterns the sales stuff because I felt
like he kind of represented everything
that's wrong in America today what
impressed Leo I think about my new life
so much is he saw me really make this
radical turn since that time he's a much
different person